Ліліан Камеску не знає, що робити далі. Раніше цей дрібний фермер тримав 26 свиней.
Але всіх довелося забити через африканську чуму.
Ось тут стояло дві свині. По той бік – ще дві.
Фермер із Росанешт зняв цю процедуру на смартфон і показує нам у сільському шинку знімки.
У селі всі обурені.
Свиней просто вбивають, кажуть селяни. Навіть не обстеживши належним чином.
Адже, можливо, тварини були здорові.
На допомогу довелося викликати поліцію, яка на собі відчула гнів людей.
В якій лабораторії проводилися аналізи крові?
Румунія не може впоратися зі своєю проблемою африканської чуми свиней.
Перші випадки хвороби трапилися у 2017 році. Але попри це понад рік не було вжито жодних заходів.
У минулому році почався масовий забій свиней.
Але в країні все ще налічується понад тисячу осередків інфекції.
Уповноважений міністр знімає із себе відповідальність.
Дехто звинувачує мене в некомпетентності, своїми справами я довів власну компетентність.
Та масштаби цієї епідемії небачені!
Ця хвороба перемогла Росію, Україну і інші країни.
У ветеринара Богдана Драгоміра негативний досвід спілкування з органами влади.
Він менеджер мисливського угіддя в окрузі Альба і пропонує комерційне полювання
та знімає відстріл звірів на відео.
І ось тепер доводиться відстрілювати всіх диких свиней в заражених регіонах.
Цього вимагає новий закон.
При цьому немає впевненості, чи такий крок взагалі може завадити
розповсюдженню африканської чуми свиней і чи не сприятиме стрес,
зумовлений полюванням, вибухові хвороби і серед диких тварин.
Це непрофесійне рішення. Відстріл 100 тисяч диких свиней в Румунії одним махом – утопія.
Цього неможливо зробити лише постановою начальства.
Їм треба показати що вони не сидять склавши руки.
От і ухвалили цей абсурдний закон. І переклали всю відповідальність на нас, на мисливців.
Саме на мисливців поклали завдання масового відстрілу.
У мисливському угідді Драгоміра африканської чуми поки що не було.
Але у сусідніх округах епідемія вже лютує.
Тому мисливцеві доводиться продовжувати підготовку до сезону полювання
і додатково вести спостереження за поголів’ям звірів,
звертаючи особливу увагу на симптоми хвороби.
Для цього він використовує автоматичні камери. 24-годинний робочий день.
При цьому владі варто було б подумати і про інші чинники, а не лише про диких свиней, каже він.
У цьому законі йдеться лише про диких свиней. Іншими факторами поширення епідемії знехтували.
Наприклад, такими хижаками, що поїдають м'ясо, як вовки або ведмеді.
Вони першими знаходять дохлих диких свиней і переносять заразу.
Немає контролю за стадами тварин та вівчарками, які теж можуть поширювати хворобу.
Колишній комісар ЄС з питань сільського господарства з Румунії Дачіан Чуолош
погоджується з цією критикою.
На мій погляд спосіб, який намагається боротися з чумою свиней в Румунії
або краще сказати те, як цього робити було б не слід, може призвести до катастрофи.
Візьмемо наприклад дезінфекцію.
Мешканці села Русанешті показують нам на скільки неефективні заходи влади.
На вході села викладені килими, котрі власне мали би бути змочені дезінфекційним засобом.
Тут мала пройти дезінфекція. Під цим приводом місцева влада привласнила бюджетні кошти.
А дезінфекцію провели простою водою. А не спецзасобами.
Зате вони вбивають наших здорових свиней.
Ось що відбувається в Румунії. Так тут управляють країною. Так ми стаємо дедалі біднішими.
Тут зовсім не дотримуються директив Європейського Союзу.
В нашій країні немає законів, є лише дурість і безглуздя.
У Ліліана Камеску залишилося тільки кілька буйволів.
Ми живемо тим, що тримаємо домашніх тварин.
Якщо наших буйволів теж оголосять хворими, нам доведеться виїхати з країни.
Чума свиней та способи протидії їй сильно вдарили по дрібних фермерах у Румунії.
Багато з них опинилися на межі виживання.